envoie une photo de toi mais qu'un
strict ça c'est un type toi que j'ai
fait récemment cela je me suis beaucoup
amusé dessus c'est un garçon qui me
demande une photo de moi avec un string
dont vous envoie une photo de moi avec à
côté en string 10 non une photo de toi
qui porte un string donc je lui renvoie
la même photo mais on je porte le string
à la main puis me demandent non une
photo de toi ou tu portes un string sur
toi donc là je me mets accroupi avec le
string sur mon dos et donc j'ai poussé
le truc jusqu'au bout j'ai un peu de mal
avec le mot se faire harceler sur les
réseaux puisque j'ai vécu du harcèlement
d'une puissance tellement énorme que
maintenant il ya d'autres choses qui
sont considérés comme du harcèlement que
moi je ressens pas comme tel par exemple
les gens que je troll sur les réseaux en
général c'est vraiment pas des messages
qui vont m'atteindre mais je sais que le
qualificatif c'est du harcèlement mais
donc ce genre de message on est toujours
reçu depuis aussi loin que je me
souvienne
oui je pense que je devrais peut-être
avoir dans les 13 14 ans la première
fois que je reçois un message à
caractère sexuel sur le réseau du jour
je te connais tu as toujours dû pour un
événement spécial que je fais tous les
jours
et pour ne laisser un bien pour itunes
ou mouline tout et ça
voilà temps voyez je n'ai pas absolument
rien reçu comment se fait-il
que ça induit dans ta vie ce harcèlement
ce type de harcèlement j'en ai vraiment
rien à cirer ça change rien à mon
quotidien dans tout ce que je me dis
c'est que c'est l'occasion de faire du
contenu marrant et qui plaît aucune
pudeur quand jean moi je suis pas
pudique mais n'importe quoi mais que
j'ai des pulls dans tous mes tics te
qu'est ce qui te fait dire ça
personnes qui sont sur les réseaux qui
sont harcelés pour se borner
en vêtements pour ma part en faire du
contenu ça m'a beaucoup aidé parce qu'en
fait quand je reçois ce genre de message
je sors un petit peu de moi même et je
suis plutôt comme un scénariste qui dit
cool qu'est-ce que je peux faire de ce
message pour en faire une histoire
marrante comment je peux le tourner pour
que ça ait l'air ridicule que en faire
une blague et donc c'est le message ne
peut plus vraiment adressé à moi mais un
personnage qui va rendre ça rigolo comme
conseil que je pourrais donner c'est se
rendre compte que le message était pas
adressée à toi en tant que personne en
fait en général c'est juste un message
de haine envers un type de personnes là
en l'occurrence les femmes n'ont pas
qu'on ait apparente de petites photos
comme ça remet tout en question celle
qui fait pitié ça a perdu ta vie une
grosse dégueulasse enfin chez pas aller
au bout d'un moment où ce calme et un il
ya des cils pour ça surtout des petits
qui te suit remettons en question passe
un peu mon âge ça avait pu chuter c'est
à l'air d'être une super joli si t'as
pas besoin de chercher à rabaisser les
autres comme ça moi je te souhaite de
trouver la confiance en toi et le
bonheur qu'en général quand le film on
voit un message de m moi je vois juste
ça comme du mal-être vois pas quel
serait l'intérêt d'aller insulter une
fille comme ça gratuitement donc en
général je leur réponds avec
bienveillance en faisant des écoutes tu
es une fille super jolie ou alors tu
dessines super bien fait en fonction de
son contenu je lui faire un compliment
et en disant t'as pas besoin de me
rabaissait pour être quelqu'un de génial
je te souhaite le meilleur hélas
systématiquement 100 % des cas sans
aucune exception elle s'excuse elles
disent ah mais non mais je voulais pas
être méchante quand tu es méchant avec
quelqu'un si en face de toi quelqu'un de
gentil tu te rends compte que tu as été
méchant gratuitement et en fait je pense
que t'en as honte récemment il ya une
vidéo qui a été beaucoup plus vu que
toutes les autres c'est une vidéo ou à
un garçon d'environ 14 ans dit qu'il va
me violer comme sur sortie de 0 contexte
est donc à bas avec quelques recherches
google j'ai trouvé toutes les infos sur
sa famille son école tout ce qu'il
fallait et donc juste envoyer un message
en disant basse à lui un tel à
l'appelant par son prénom et je lui
demande des nouvelles de toute sa
famille en citant tous les prénoms en
citant le nom de son école et en me
disant oh bah écoute moi je reviens
prévenir tes parents mais j'ai pas leur
numéro donc demain matin je vais appeler
ton école pourra pour les prévenir là
j'ai eu une flopée de messages ou il
s'excuse ou il me supplient de rien fait
hindi je suis juste un petit tu peux pas
faire ça pendant ma petite enquête
j'avais échangé avec une personne qui
était visiblement dans son école et qui
m'a dit qu'il était déjà suivi par
l'apci de l'école ou quelque chose comme
ça pour comportement inapproprié avec
les filles donc visiblement pas son coup
d'essai dans ce cas là je peux vraiment
pas laisser passer
je me dis qu'il vaut peut-être mieux
qu'ils se fassent engueuler une bonne
fois pour toutes à 14 ans et ne plus
jamais commettre l'erreur que continuer
dans cette voie là et un jour ça tirait
des vrais gros ennuis il ya des gens qui
critiquent en disant que c'est pas cool
que je fais du mal à ce pauvre garçon
moi je pense plutôt que je lui rends
service il ya des messages qui sont
vraiment beaucoup trop grave et là je me
contente pas de trop laid ou d'en faire
un contenu aussi tout ce qui se passe en
off et dans ces cas là bas je vais
déposer plainte quand c'est vraiment
trop grave et en fait il faut savoir que
toutes les plateformes sont tenus
légalement de divulguer toutes les
informations de l'utilisateur dès
l'instant où il ya une plainte il ya
ceux sur qui je dors enquêter pitt à
ceux qui sont vraiment des génies ultime
il y en a il n'y a pas très longtemps
qui m'envoyait une suite de messages
ultra déplacer à base de jeu belge de
viol sale [__] sauf que dans sa bio la
seule chose qu'il avait écrite
s'est-elle @ de sa copine en précisant
que c'est sa copine ce qui n'est pas
très malin donc marc en deux clics
j'avais trouvé sa copine et je lui
envoyais la capture donc parfois les
gens sont pas super malin